the fast-food story of the week this is
really interesting so a chiropractor in
Nebraska he has been displaying a
two-year-old mcdonald happy meal in his
office as a way of hoping that it'll
show his patients to eat healthier uh
very so that's two years old that looks
pretty pretty similar to it to a two
hour old happy male doesn't it I mean
that doesn't look that different right
this is completely the air is it it's
exposed cetera et cetera to be fair the
guy put it in one of those cake domes
right but it's not completely right
that's not here say something I made
muffins once and put them in the cake
dome yeah for like three weeks they were
fine they were like still moist and
fantastic so I need to add two years or
so he would eat that but I think this is
more a commercial for the cake dough so
listen ironically he's selling cakes on
the side I think that a slight
difference between the three-week old
muffin in the booth all due respect to
your muffins in the cake dome then the
you know the two-year old McDonald's but
we also have any image this one's wild
uh this is a 14 year old McDonald's
Happy Meal yeah now 40 years old if by
all logic we would all think it would be
rotted and molded and pretty much fun
guide and give me another word really
you Peter
Oh Doris and decomposing Mastiffs I'd
but it is not now we should say here
that McDonald's uh has acknowledged that
these burgers don't rot and claims the
food are dehydrated so they don't rot in
the absence of water therefore claiming
is an abundance of chemicals that's
doing this now we've also talked about
McDonald's pink slime in the burgers and
last week we did the story about the
yoga mat chemical that is in all the
breads at all the fast food places and
every time we do a story on this people
the comment section go crazy saying well
we have chemicals and everything and it
said that you shouldn't have too much of
the chemical but if you want a little
yoga mat chemical in your bread then
that's okay is that that so that
argument we just talked about that argue
yes we have chemicals in everything and
we're constantly inhaling all kinds of
things and at one time people thought
asbestos was okay and bla bla bla but
shouldn't we have just like a basic rule
you don't need these things even if we
even if there's somehow sort of harmless
now that we don't need yoga mat
chemicals that expand elasticity and
that's why they put it in the bread and
that's why the subway bread is so fluffy
yeah
am I am I wild radical when I say that
no I I mean I've heard of like metal
fillings being in like Wheaties and
stuff like you're holding magnets up to
them I know so what is except what
what's the acceptable level of ore that
I'm eating yeah what is it but um know
if the food doesn't decompose I don't
think I should put it in my body um that
said there was a receipt somebody was
showing a receipt yeah it cost like 79
cents fourteen years ago for that
hamburger the receipt was decomposing so
basically it would be healthier to eat
the receipt yeah then it would to eat
the patty what do you say to these
people who say science and it's if you
don't have too much of the chemical I
would like to see them dehydrate a piece
of grade-a sirloin
you know and see if that holds up as
well as as the pink slime post 14 years
also I'd like to meet this guy who kept
a burger for 14 years right you got to
wonder about that did he do it on
purpose
he forgot but I drove by McDonald's
yesterday said billions and billions
served and I'm thinking there are
billions and billions of those hamburger
patties in the universe somewhere so
it's like Cloudy with a Chance of
hamburger a bit of whoppers or whenever
they're fall well speaking of billions
billions served there was also a thing
that came out today that McDonald's has
right now I kid you not
10 million extra pounds of chicken wings
their mighty wings they're not selling
so they have 10 million extra pounds is
this just like a whole problem with our
it's our food source and why and all the
whole fat it's just like the whole
socio-economic thing and is a big now
what people aren't even mighty wing you
like the mighty way this is the research
they didn't do the research and up to
know the people wouldn't eat the might
of it yeah well I think it is McDonald's
hears people saying listen you don't
serve actual food in your happy meal it
is a miserable
meal and the and so they try to give you
now their menus are bright and green if
you look at the McDonald's breakfast
menu on the drive-through window
everything's on plates which has never
happened to an egg McMuffin no one's
like okay let me put it on a plate and
have a nice cup of coffee that I pour my
you know McDonald's coffee into right
and then there's leafy greens now as
opposed to the shredded lettuce that
they've had on things in the past and so
for the mighty winged they wanted it to
look like an actual animal part and
people are like no I find I don't care I
like that sometimes it's like a game
when I bite the McNugget when am I gonna
get that like gelatinous unchi Obul ball
from spinning the chicken in a circle
and taking whatever clip sticks to the
outside and putting it in a Nuggets or
whatever clitoris whatever it looks like
I just want to eat chicken cleaner and
if we can make that happen actually some
of the mighty wings kind of do look like
a big clip like this but it's like fast
food that is slow to decompose yeah so
you get it in fast and never get out can
I share of personal stories cuz I don't
think the clitoris stories personal
baskin-robbins ice cream cake Oh doesn't
melt
I left my intimate chocolate cheap no no
the sun's dome out of the dome in my
kitchen I like had a party in a cake and
I got drunk and went to sleep and I came
back the next morning to the kitchen and
it is just this this large sponge it is
it it yes it kind of deflate s-- but
that ice cream you would imagine would
melt and it just does not wow so there's
something you know so she hydrated right
ice cream cream
all right so final thought on it so
everyone always says well if you
Americans if you want your food cheap
and you want it fast well then we have
to put all this stuff in there and
that's and then they also say well you
know the people that are on the lower
end of the economic
I'm excaliferb this stuff but I don't
even think that argument makes any sense
because it doesn't a happy meal or a
number one a Big Mac meal cost around
seven or eight bucks at McDonald's in my
ballpark UNIX a mask of the wrong person
yeah McDonald's over to pass like that
650 let's go okay didn't come out for
615 so 650 couldn't you for 650 go to
Trader Joe's I know there's not Trader
Joe's everywhere like there is a
McDonald's but get not only a healthy
meal for 650 but more than one meal you
get a bag of kale for a moment about
Trader Joe's am I in there and they're
in their sodium bricks that they
everyone's the cheap special Trader
Joe's is frozen stuff that's the cheap
stuff at Trader Joe's and that is not
good for you but you could get a bag of
kale at Trader Joe's for like two bucks
and a wrap that's basically put it on
the plate put it on a plate and eat that
and it'll be the same price so does that
economic or am I just being ambien are
you try being an elitist have you tried
to park it Trader - it really is a
question of convenience yeah right yeah
that that's why people drive through
I'll have number one it's so much easier
then yeah you just came up with so
Trader Joe's had the drive-thru we might
have solved something here I just think
your problem is that you just told
America to eat its vegetables yeah I
apologize I retract that whole thing I
completely apologize about that